you know shout out to trey young i know
he can watch what you think about his
haircut i feel i've never seen him with
a fresh haircut
no no offense straight young what's good
it's your boy vic blinds i'm out here
bleacher report for the nba tip off 2021
and we're trying to find some nba fans
to give a free haircut too so let's get
it
free haircuts for nba fans okay cool i'm
a nba fan
as long as you do an nba fan
all right let's do it
i usually don't let anybody just cut my
hair you know i got barbara ptsd what do
you got when you get all this [ __ ]
bro
yeah i think lebron and the lakers would
be gonna be in it again for sure
they got an all-star team right now
right i mean if they don't win then
that's just embarrassing
what's your predictions for the hawks
i think they gonna do good only because
i have to
like me i'm real loyal when it comes to
stuff like that so even if we don't do
good you know
i'm still going to rock him what's that
take out right beside him yeah you got
to what do you think about trey on his
haircut
i feel i've never seen him with a fresh
airflow no no offense trey young you
might need to cut it all off
you need a better barber right yeah
i wonder who be cutting
i don't know
[Music]
i guess not you think you need a better
barber yeah
how often
pretty often he gets to come pretty
often bro but it's tv it's tv i'm gonna
say that's tv he's hard working man
though man you know when you sweat you
know yeah
i'm just going to say you know probably
got a small tv
you want that nice i got the clips of
your head
what was your first basketball member uh
playing with my dad outside
like one of the one of the hoops
my dad like just
beated me like like i used to try to
play him all the time he would just beat
me over and over and over again and it
kind of made me want to get better just
so i can beat him
yeah that was literally my only goal
your sports learn a lot of values man
it's about teamwork
uh accountability
it's dedication working hard
lifelong friendships
how has basketball helped
change your life
basketball helped change me because
there's a lot of times where
i have two different fragrances i have
you know the frankfurter does the good
things when i have a friend really does
bad things and it just so happens i hope
so much that i never have time to do it
my friends they get in trouble
it saved me a lot was an escape for you
yeah i feel like it's an escape for a
lot of kids nowadays back in the game
mustache going crazy
get out too
i appreciate it
[Music]